vas-y mon bouder ça a été un honneur
pour moi d'être coupé par chantal bâtard
et jean baptiste liquide peut faire que
tu veux faire
chantal est ce que je fais chaque vague
cette émission spéciale chansons et
c'est sûr vas-y bouder vas-y écoute la
plagne de brouillard total écoute la
blague de bouder alors je t'explique le
pape c'est dimanche soir hig a l'air un
peu comment dans son chauffeur et lui
dit qu'est ce que vous faites vous ce
soir et déjà écouter ce soir ma santé
c'est mon anniversaire à débat vous
savez quoi je vais vous faire une petite
balade dans rome et ces voix qui va
conduire cette fois ci le chauffeur
était content leurs rivaux dans la
voiture et c'est le pape qui conduit le
pape qui conduisent balade un peu et un
moment 2010 voulais pas te mettre sur
l'autoroute et le chauffeur et dima
santé si vous voulez aller sur
l'autoroute a pas de problème car le
plat il prend la voiture et maintenant
il se fait flasher 250 km heure il ya
deux motards qui le poursuivent ils
arrêtent le premier motard et d'avoir
aidé à voir le conducteur dit bonjour il
s'aperçoit que le conducteur c'est le
pape il dit à m'insulter je suis un peu
je sais pas quoi vous dire mais nous
savons que flash à 250 ch obligé de vous
verbaliser est le deuxième policier dit
non à temps j'en appelle notre chef et
on lui demande alors il appelle le chef
chef on a flashé un mec à 250 kilomètres
heure il déplace bien verbalisé le dire
on ne peut pas c'est quelqu'un de très
hauts placés
alors le chef leur dit c'est qui le
premier ministre dit non encore plus
haut tiens c'est qui le président et
dinan plus haut que le président la
république passé qui cotisent et je
crois que c'est dieu j'ai commencé assez
dieu et dis oui je crois que c'est dieu
parce que son chauffeur c'est le pape
[Rires]
c'est bien s'est bien passé
je trie mes déchets semblions ses tubes
animaliades avec plaisir alors
cendrillon les très vieilles l'assistant
27 ans et tout d'un coup elle vit tout
seul parce que le prince charmant est
mort et albi pour seule avec son chat
qui s'appelle bob et et tout d'un coup
elle a une idée géniale elle dit je vais
quand même rappeler ma marraine c'est
peut-être qu'elle existe encore et
qu'elle est immortel marraine mme harel
mais où es tu est la marraine arrive
exactement la même que dans le walt
disney elle n'a pas changé elle a pas
bougé et ben alors mais pourquoi tu n'as
pas appelé avant on m'arrête je suis
tellement heureuse de voir écoute tu as
trois voeux à faire demande moi tout ce
que tu veux donc cendrillon sont prêts
si elle lui dit j'aimerais la jeunesse
qui voit parce que là je suis tout
décrépit j'ai vieilli chuterait vieil
homme un coup de baguette magique elle
vit donne la jeunesse elle est à nouveau
très belle et tout d'un coup elle lui
dit un deuxième but maintenant est lui
dit la richesse parce que je suis devenu
très très pauvre
alors là fait un coup de baguette
magique et elle lui donne un grande
grande mal comme ça avec eux des lingots
d'or elle est très heureuse et un
troisième veut maintenant alors elle dit
tu sais maintenant je suis si seul
j'aimerais que tu transformes pub en
prince charmant et tout d'un coup elle
prend la vague est comme ça king sur le
chat et le chien se transforme en d'une
bombe
un mec super beau tout va bien elle est
très heureuse merci marraine merci et
elle s'avance comme ça pour embrasser
son prince charmant et tout d'un coup il
lui dit et maintenant je vais te faire
regretter de m'avoir castet paul et
chantal tu as compris des chinois
et voilà